meanwhile legion stadium had a crowd
about 100 men and women who were going
through typical raiders boot camp drills
they were from nellis and creech air
force bases here in southern nevada as
part of the usaa's salute to boot camp a
great opportunity to put these service
men and women out on the field and put
them through some paces former raider
quarterback jay schroeder was out there
today the the idea really here is to
bring raiders together with the local
military community
this is a blessing and an honor to come
out and help support our veterans in
everything we do
been fortunate enough throughout my
career to always help and you know
continue that today being out here we
are so
appreciative of the las vegas raiders
and everything they did
for the nellis airmen the crete chairman
and the airmen of the vatican training
range today the entire event
read camaraderie excitement
it allowed a lot of our athletes to show
some of their skills it's awesome to be
out here today
with the men and women from nellis air
force base and creature air force base
we're here
out here with the raiders
because usaa is the official salute to
service partner with the raiders
well the air men and women were also at
this morning's raiders training camp so
they got to see the team up close and
personal while also being able to work
out with the raiders on that home turf
turner